this video is about the debris
hypothesis which supposedly says matter
is a wave as well as a particle and this
equation that tells us how to find the
wavelength of that particle the issue is
there is a very precise way to interpret
the hypothesis that leads to interesting
questions about quantum mechanics but
instead it's often stated in an almost
meaningless ly imprecise form let's fix
that this video is a little more
involved than the previous ones but
hopefully not too bad and if I fail
don't worry you don't need to understand
all of this video to understand the next
ones if you do want to stick around
though I'd recommend a little revision
for us because it's been a while and in
particular watch these videos if you can
ok so we've got this particle it's got a
wave function remember the wave function
of a particle contains everything we can
know about that particle for example it
might say that the particle is in a
superposition of being here here and
here and so if you measure its position
then it will turn up in one of those
places there are these special wave
functions called position eigen States
this means that the particle really is
in one spot if you measure it it will
definitely be there but wave functions
don't just tell us about the position of
a particle it also tells us about the
speed or momentum of the particle for
example there is a way to convert the
wave function from the position basis to
the momentum one when you do it you
could find your particle is in a
superposition of several speeds here's
the question we'll focus on if the
particle is going at one speed so the
wave function is a momentum eigenstate
then where is it how do we write that
wave function in the position basis is
it a superposition of many places or is
it just in one spot if this were
everyday life at any point in time a
moving particle is still only in one
spot but what we'll see is even at a
particular time a momentum eigenstate is
a superposition of many positions in
fact all of them equally I'll show how
we motivate this
just like with North assumes we do some
thought experiments about how the state
could be different suppose we have some
superposition of locations we just
imagine what if these places had been a
bit to the right instead we'll call this
offset amount Delta and as you can see
position wave functions are the same but
just Delta to the right remember the way
we define this shift the position is
changed but the speeds the particles are
going at is not so imagine our original
wave function had instead been a
momentum eigenstate then what happens to
that when it shifted we'd expect this
wave function is exactly the same right
because the shift doesn't affect the
speed and so it should still be the same
momentum eigenstate well actually that
doesn't mean the wave function has to be
exactly the same we definitely want it
to be going at the same speed if we
measure it but that still allows a bit
of freedom because remember the
probability of a particular speed is the
length of the coefficient of the complex
number sitting in front of here now
imagine if the state had had a negative
1 in front of it instead negative 1
still has length 1 and so there's still
a probability of 1 what about if there
had been an eye there instead that still
has length 1 as well and so it would be
the same thing in fact if we go back to
thinking of complex numbers as arrows
all complex numbers on this circle have
length 1 in physics we call these
numbers phases there's a really
convenient way to represent a phase
suppose the space has angle theta using
our trigonometry we could write that as
a complex number like this now we're
just going to define the complex
exponential to be this expression
because it's convenient and it means
that we can write down this phase just
using this one more useful fact about
phases that we're going to use a bit
later is that if you multiply any
complex number by a phase that's just
the same as rotating that complex number
by the angle so getting back to the
point we require that when you shift
momentum eigenstate in position it
doesn't change momentum but it may pick
up a phase this phase obviously needs to
depend on the amount of shifting Delta
and also on the momentum and so those
two things should go into this angle
almost done but we need some number
that's just going to scale how much this
angle changes when everything else
changes so let's just pick a name for it
how about h-bar yep the famous quantum
mechanics constant that's in all of
those important equations this is its
grand entry it's just some constant that
decides how much a shift changes the
phase we can measure it in some other
ways and it turns out to be this very
very small number ok we're almost there
but first we've got to talk a little bit
more about position wave functions I've
talked about the wave function when it's
a superposition of a few different spots
but the thing is a particle could be in
a superposition of a whole infinite
range of positions right what if the
particle is in a superposition of all of
these places but it's more likely to
turn up in this area say how would we
represent that before we put a complex
number in front of each of the positions
now we're basically going to do the same
thing but we'll assign a complex number
to every single point the particle could
be in other words a complex number for
every point on the line assigning a
complex number to every point on the
line
that's just a complex function we'll
call it f of X the bigger the complex
number the more likely the particle is
to turn up around there complex
functions are kind of annoying to draw
but there are two ways we can do it
either we can just draw the real part
and the imaginary part out separately or
we can draw it in 3d with the real bit
coming out towards you and the imaginary
bit going up so all complex numbers are
still just arrows both are useful for
people who've seen calculus before all
I'm saying is that the wave function can
be written as an integral of all of the
possible positions where each position
is weighed by this complex function if
that
no sense at all to you don't worry it's
really not important anyway we have this
momentum eigenstate and we want to write
it in the position basis we know that
the position wavefunction is going to be
represented by one of these complex
functions but we just need to find it
now this is what we know when you
translate the momentum eigenstate it
stays the same except possibly picks up
an overall phase then since this
function f of X is the momentum
eigenstate it represents it it must do
that same thing well there is a function
that fits that bill actually and it's
this complex squiggly function where
that blue bit is the real one and the
red is the imaginary in other words this
function is a complex exponential with
this wavelength now why is this the wave
function that we're looking for well you
can already see it almost has
translation symmetry the function is the
same if you shift it over a bit only
it's a little bit rotated but that's
exactly what would happen if you
multiplied by a phase remember
multiplying any complex number by a
phase just rotates it by that angle and
so translating this function is just the
same as multiplying it by a phase just
what we wanted now we've actually
derived the debreu hypothesis see all it
actually said was the wave function of a
particle with one particular momentum is
the complex exponential with this
wavelength then why the confusion about
this wave particle duality where people
say that the particle acts like a wave
sometimes and a particle sometimes I
think that the problem is that for a
confusing time before quantum mechanics
people were doing things like the double
slit experiment and for understandable
reasons interpreted them using the wave
particle duality and that's kind of
stuck but let me show you an alternative
explanation using all of our current
quantum mechanics the way the double
slit experiment or single slit
experiment is done is just by firing
particles let's say atoms each atom is
prepared so that it has exactly one
momentum in other words it's wave
function
is a momentum eigenstate and so let's
just look at the real part of that wave
function and it looks like a wave if we
have a single slit then that wave once
it goes through the slit will spread out
just like a water wave would then we
measure where the particles end up as
you can see the wave function is biggest
in the middle and so that's where each
particle is most likely to land but
that's what we would have expected even
if we were just throwing regular
particles you know so people thought
this is purely particle-like behavior
the double slit experiment then should
be similar each particle goes through
one slit and lands most likely right
behind that slit of course instead they
got this this is how you explain this
with quantum mechanics since we don't
measure which door the particle goes
through each particles wavefunction is a
superposition of going through both
doors that means we add the separate
wave functions together if the waves
were in sync like they are at these
points because the crests meet other
crests and the troughs meet other
troughs the result is a really big wave
but here the waves are totally out of
sync and so there's no wave left there
at all they cancel the result is that
there are these alternating spots where
the wave function is very big and then
small and then big again etc etc and
that gets you that right result but
instead people thought that now the
particle is acting like a wave but it
wasn't before as you can see our current
interpretation is much more subtle but
covers both cases in the same framework
people also imagine that the particle
itself smeared out into a physical wave
but somehow collected itself back up
into a point particle when measured at
the wall now we say that the particle
itself is doing who-knows-what when it's
not being measured if it exists at all
but it's wave function is the one that
spreads out honestly I'm not sure why
people who know quantum mechanics still
talk about the wave particle duality at
all
maybe because it seems easier to explain
than the wave function but it annoys me
because it makes the world sound so
paradoxical that we couldn't possibly
hope to comprehend it
anyway thanks
for watching this video I know I've been
away for far far far too long as a
reward for your loyalty here's some
homework firstly what did you think of
my supposed derivation of the momentum
wavefunction what assumptions did I make
that you think needed a bit more
justification secondly Niels Bohr was a
huge proponent of the wave particle
duality and what he called
complementarity even long after the
modern form of quantum mechanics try and
understand his interpretation of these
concepts and report back okay see you
very soon for the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle